私 a
砂絵匹行ったことありますか多分小学校の時とかも開か段昇段とか関白綱引き行った
ことがあると思うんですけども大人になってから綱引きやる機会あんまりないと思い
ますして焦って僕ちょっと最近筋トレしてるんであの筋肉結構あるんですよ
この筋肉を持ってればそうの小さい子どもたちであれば集団でかかってきても多分室
ノリでも勝てると思うんですよ事ってかかってきても残酷仏塔すると思うんで今日の
検証は子どもたち何人まで僕は勝ってるのか検証していきたいと思いますとだけで
子どもたちの皆に来てもらっておりますみんな修造
アコスから
はいというわけで今日は皆にやってもらいました
[拍手]
おちちゃんにー中 j ちゃんぬーん
までかかってきても勝てるかなという実験をしたいんだ今日は分配サーフ撮りたい一人
でよって
鷹辻ちゃんさんそれから月からどんどん人増やしていこう何にまでかてもらっているの
ではやっていきましょう
[拍手]
愛という早速小学生は一人ずつぶっ倒していきましょう
ルールがじゃあこの菌はリサイクルがあるんですけどもいいいい奴がこの日あそして
審判はフィリピンから来てリョサ
こちらのジャッジの here 好調関係なく
私全力で潰しにかかりますのでよろしくお願いしますかかってこいやー
結構迷ってますこれ
御願いしまーす
[音楽]
そこであげるわけない間からさーん
[拍手]
それはございません
さあ
ああああああ
あっはぁこれが俺の力だ
クロス続いで2人です午後しっかり勝ちたいところでありません
じゃあよろしくお願いします
います
べっ
ていました
ん
くださいん
ませんそこまでがんばれがんばれがんばです
いいいいいで1対3でちょっと寄ったりでちょっと親と思ったんですけど3件もさすが
に行けると思います頑張っていたじゃあ
大丈夫いやー
はぁしし
これで4人目で今後の円本をします
はーいああ
web
おおおおお経
ああああああ
goo
ええええええ
par
[音楽]
car
まだ買っていますそれで後に行きましょう
ああああああ
今日はいいいい
[拍手]
tee
うっさー使うすけ
どんなは者
それ52行きましたまたまた高いサーダナ6人でいきましょースターっ
[拍手]
はぁぁ
ん
ああああああ
wh
[拍手]
ああああああ
me
一見不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
もうもうず一定がたとえならネイチャーそう
あって怖いけど運ゲー
4位
rar
[音楽]
me
dea
uh
結構頑張った方だと思うよなやっはいこれ
ああああああ
えっまだいっちゃ経験をつかうけどなあああ
dj
ダガーはぁ
ああああああ
dj koo
ran
[拍手]